the body of the Dragon oh I'm so nervous
I'm so nervous
hey guys it's Inca so last time I made
dragon beards candy today I'm gonna try
painting with sugar sugar painting has
been around for centuries it is this
amazing art form where people use sugar
to paint different characters anything
from rabbits to monkeys to dragons when
I was traveling around China I saw these
artists on the streets and I thought it
was the most amazing thing I am not
really an artist I don't even have a
recipe for this so I'm just going to be
winging it it's going to be great sugar
painting first things first I have no
idea what sugar I'm gonna use so I'm
just going to test out different types
and different ratios for a first attempt
we're gonna go with one cup of rock
sugar and one cup of water I think I'm
supposed to boil the water first here we
go
really you need a little bit more I'm
supposed to continue stirring this
[Music]
now it's looking a lot stickier you see
that hope it means we're on the right
track I'm gonna turn it down now I'm
just wondering if it's supposed to
bubble this much this doesn't look like
the right color did i overcook it oh my
god it is crystallizing I failed let's
go for round two
round two we are going to do one cup of
sugar and two cups of water
fingers crossed I'm gonna go with white
sugar this time I am NOT gonna stir it
we'll see how that goes so right now we
have the sticky gooey looking liquid
it's not quite the right color but it
was better than our first attempt get
some out and put it into cold water it's
hot tastes good but I don't think it's
what we're looking for I can't really
draw with this this is not how it's
supposed to be
we have failed yet again I don't know
what to do to make this right I don't
know what I'm doing wrong I can't figure
out this sugar how can I get to painting
we're gonna end it here and try
something different yeah we can cut I am
freaking out right now because we were
gonna give up for the day and I had cut
all the cameras so I'm on my phone right
now but look at this color oh my god
I'm so excited right now one second I'm
gonna pour it out
[Music]
well guys have been such a good shot
it's so I'm gonna break it apart like it
tastes like what I had I am so excited
so I broke them into little pieces you
can see right there and now I am going
to reset everything back up clean all
the dishes and we're gonna start
painting yes so we're rolling again I
have my sugar candy bits in the mason
jar you could totally eat this as it
smells really good I'm just gonna melt
this on low heat this might take awhile
[Music]
this is all like drawing consistency I
[Music]
think so I think you might be ready
my main goal today is to draw a dragon
that is like the ultimate goal but we're
gonna have to do some practicing first I
should probably start with something
easier let's try
[Music]
this is me trying to draw home country
that's the easiest thing I can think of
this is a bad butterfly while I wanted
to go from this to a dragon I think
we're being very optimistic here oh I
know it's not much to look at but it's
my first please bear with me
oh this is the first of its kind this
could belong to like the mome RA let's
do this
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh my God we're so close a little bit
more it's a little bit more ok there's
almost a little bit more like a
butterfly I'm scared what's the best way
Oh
[Music]
does it look like a butterfly we're
slowly getting there
is it so stressful it is about time for
me to really go out there and do a
dragon only got one shot so let's try
whoo I'm so nervous I'm so nervous
[Music]
I don't even know if I can lift it up
[Music]
so this is what we have so far now the
challenge is to pick it up I am so
nervous right now I don't even know
where to start
[Music]
glue is back oh oh my god oh my god
[Music]
here we go it's all or nothing I can't
believe I did it it's a friggin dragon
I'm like so scared I'm gonna drop it
[Music]
like I can't believe I actually did what
I thought was impossible I definitely
burn the sugar towards the end
definitely a lot of room for improvement
but I'm pretty satisfied I would love to
know what you guys want me to make next
and see y'all next time
[Music]